so area codes came about in such an
organic way this is my first time
traveling the world going from City to
city and definitely picking up numbers
and howling at women in every single
City so I had this mental Rolodex no
matter where I was at I know if I was in
Jersey I was like 201 if I'm in New York
718 you know I would have all these
different numbers and we were sitting in
a limo one day the whole crew and
somebody was like oh what's 305 and we
was like that's Miami that's one of your
hoes in Miami you know somebody else was
ringing it'd be like oh it's 813 oh man
that's Tampa man you got to know that so
it was almost like this extreme game
that we would play because we would
never record their names until we just
got the phone number so you'd have to
remember what city every area code came
to so that record is 100 organic